CBS News has confirmed that the CDC will
release guidelines later today on
reopening churches which President Trump
describes as essential the president
visited his third battleground state
yesterday touring a Ford plant in
Michigan he was told to wear a mask and
carried one but he refused to wear it in
front of the TV cameras been Tracie
reports from the White House on that
President Trump held a navy blue mask in
his hand and explained his reason the
president was seen in this photo briefly
wearing the mask ford sources tell CBS
News that chairman Bill Ford expected
President Trump to wear it the entire
time / the strict policy of the plant
and was surprised when he took it off
the state's governor Gretchen Whitmer
called the president's decision not to
wear a mask during the tour
disappointing this is really important
that anyone with a platform has a
responsibility to make sure that they
model precisely what we're asking
everyone else to do this is about public
health not one person's or another
the president has class with Widmer and
his visit came just a day after he
threatened to withhold federal funding
from the state upset by Michigan's plans
to expand vote-by-mail for upcoming
elections President Trump claims without
any evidence that mail-in voting leads
to widespread election fraud with a
second wave of coronavirus expected to
hit this fall or winter states are
trying to plan for elections while also
keeping people safe
but President Trump says if there's a
second wave he won't shut the country
down again whether it's an ember or a
flame we're going to put it out but
we're not closing our country now
Michigan's Attorney General had warned
President Trump that it was state law
that he wear a mask inside that plant
president Trump fired back on Twitter
overnight calling her a wacky do-nothing
Agee saying she should be careful or
Ford may leave Michigan I mean while
flags here at the
white house and at all federal buildings
across the country are flying at
half-staff in honor of those who have
lost their lives to coronavirus Anthony
then thank you